so let's take a look at how to implement
app cache in our conference application
first we go into our HTML file and we
add the manifest in our manifest file we
list in the cache section all of the
static resources for our application our
JavaScript files our CSS our fav icon
all of the images we need to use but
note one file that's missing our index
HTML any page that points to the
manifest that is that has that magic
manifest equal in the HTML element is
implicitly cached which can very easily
get out of control it's kind of hard to
get them out of the cash once they're in
it which is why we're only using the
manifest attribute on this one page note
though in the network section we put the
Google Analytics javascript file and all
the Maps API servers we can't really
useful e-cash these API servers so we'll
have to be online for now now let's go
back to our app and with the dev tools
console open let's reload and see what
happens you can see in the console a
whole bunch of application cache
messages if we go up to the top of this
you can see it's creating an application
cache based on this file it checks that
and then it starts downloading all of
the resources that are inside that
manifest when it completes it sends us
an event that says the application cache
is cached now if we reload the page
again we get a much shorter set this
time it says the document was loaded
from the application cache tells us
where the manifest is it checks the cash
but there's no update ready so it
doesn't bother doing anything